un statut similaire aux pupilles de la
nation pour les enfants de soignants
mort du co vite 19
c'est ce que voudraient certains députés
pupille de la nation un statut née après
la première guerre mondiale pour venir
en aide aux 750 mille orphelins de
guerre après la deuxième guerre mondiale
près de 250 mille enfants sont reconnue
pupille de la nation
ce statut cette adoption par la nation
garantit une aide de morale et une
protection financière jusqu'à l'âge de
21 ans s'est alors l'office national des
anciens combattants et victimes de
guerre qui gère ses pupilles
les années passent et la guerre change
de visage au début des années 80 la
france est victime d'une vague
d'attentats commando de quatre hommes a
ouvert le feu peu après 13h dans le
restaurant traiteur jo goldenberg situé
rue des rosiers des associations
plaident d'alors pour étendre le statut
de victimes de guerre pour les blessés
et les morts d'attentât terroriste et
donc par conséquent d'étendre le statut
de pupille de la nation pour les
orphelins
c'est chose faite avec la loi de
finances de 1990 ce statut va nous
permettre d'obtenir les soins gratuits
d'obtenir les appareillages gratuit
l'accès aux centres de soins réservé aux
militaires et le statut de pupille de la
nation pour les orphelins achik des
emplois réservés
en 2005 suite au meurtre d'une
infirmière et d'une aide-soignante par
un patient dans un hôpital psychiatrique
de pau le statut de pupille de la nation
évolue encore les enfants de lucette
gharios et chantal climat zewski pupille
de la nation et ce sera le cas
dorénavant pour tous les enfants nés
professionnels de santé victimes
d'homicide volontaire par des patients
dans l'exercice de leurs fonctions une
reconnaissance qui n'allait pas assez
loin pour les représentants syndicaux
dans une interview prémonitoire au
niveau des hôpitaux en général avec tous
les nouveaux virus qui arrivent les
nouvelles maladies serait bien aussi que
ce soit reconnue
pour les problèmes de maladies en 2012
le statut de pupille de la nation
s'élargit encore avec les enfants de
fonctionnaires
gendarmes policiers mais aussi
professeur ou diplomates mort dans
l'exercice de leurs fonctions après les
attentats de 2015 l'office national des
anciens combattants et victimes de
guerre rappelait encore sa mission les
aides à la vie quotidienne des
subventions aux études c'est eux c'est
presque l'aide la plus importante
il ya des étrennes de l'office une aide
à la majorité et une aide au premier
emploi un ordinateur une caution pour un
loyer à l'achat de véhicules en 2015 le
budget des 422 pupilles de moins de 21
ans s'est élevé à 1 million d'euros
[Musique]